What I'd like to share
with you this evening is
some of my latest
work for National
Geographic about sharks.
Or as we say where I come
from in Massachusetts, sharks.
Over the last two
years I've worked on
four separate projects.
Four separate stories about
the top predatory species
of sharks on planet earth.
And the idea was,
this was done in hopes
by running em as Greg said,
by running these stories
consecutively in the
magazine, we ran three of em,
one more upcoming.
The idea was to sort
of give these animals
somewhat of a makeover.
I think the hope at least
my hope was to change
or replace fear with respect.
Because nobody respects
sharks more than I do.
Believe me, nobody respects
sharks more than me.
But what I also
wanted to do tonight,
in addition to showing
some of this brand new work
or the latest work was to
include some earlier work
that might give a little
context to these new stories
because for me sharks have
been sort of this life long
pursuit, something
that has fascinated me
for a very long time and
I wanted to sort of give
context to how I arrived
at these new stories
by looking at some
of the early stuff.
I actually saw my very
first shark in the wild,
back in 1982.
It was off the coast of Rhode
Island in very murky waters
out there, I was about
20 years old at the time
and I had been invited to join
a group of marine biologists
that were doing their own
sort of little private trips
out there and they were
lead by a scientist named
West Pratt, who built
his own shark cage,
sort of this little chicken
wire cage that he made.
And he would go off shore and
put a little chum in the water
and hope to see
mostly blue sharks.
So I can remember
standing in that cage
just below the surface on
sort of a mildly rough day
and waiting for hours just
staring out into the gloom,
hoping to see a shark.
I was just about
ready to give up hope
when at about four o'
clock that afternoon,
that first shark appeared.
It was a female blue
shark, about six feet long.
And the instant I saw her,
I was both instantly amazed
and sort of hypnotized,
stunned by that beautiful
blue color that they
have on their backs,
sort of glowed in
that afternoon light.
Without really thinking
about I, opened the door
of the shark cage
and swam outside.
Because the shark wasn't
coming close enough to the cage
and I really wanted to get
close and to make pictures.
The scientist later told me
that I was the first person
to ever swim outside the cage,
but I just had to get close,
I needed to be up
close to this animal.
Now my heart was racing
in those moments,
there was a real
mix of emotions.
On one hand I was thinking,
what do I do if she comes at me?
What do I do if she
tries to bite me?
And on the other hand
I was just so thrilled
to finally be out there
in the middle of the ocean
with this gorgeous animal.
She moved elegantly
through the water,
sort of meandering
her way around,
coming pretty close at times
and clearly aware of my
presence but really paid me
little attention.
It was as if she was
on her own mission,
some ancient journey
that didn't include me
and I was just a
momentary distraction.
After a few minutes,
she sort of just
moved away from me
and swam toward the boat.
And I watched her glide into
the shadows and then disappear
into that late day light.
She was gone.
And once again I found
myself, sort of just,
drifting alone in that
emerald green sea,
feeling like I was
waking up from a dream
and wondering if it
was all really true,
if this had really happened,
this first encounter.
Now the first encounter
that I had with a wild shark
as I said happened when
I was about 20 years old.
That was four years after I
became a certified scuba diver.
My very first C card right here.
I was about 16 years old.
Kinda stunning actually
how little I've changed
since I was 16.
But I became a diver because
I had this deep desire
to explore the ocean and to
photograph animals like sharks.
That was a big reason why
I wanted to become a diver.
And until I had that first
experience with the blue shark,
these animals seemed almost
like mythical creatures to me,
like a unicorn.
I'd read about them but until
you actually are in their
presence, it doesn't
really seem real.
So that first experience
with the blue shark,
had me completely
hooked, no pun intended.
I really knew that
I needed more,
that I wanted more.
There was something
about these animals
that captivated me,
that fascinated me
and I knew I had to get
back out into the sea
as often as I could.
Just brief moments even
with these animals.
They're difficult to photograph
and it takes a lot to get
out there and see them but,
I knew that if I could just get
out there a little bit more,
maybe I could
satisfy that desire.
I think part of what
attracted me to these animals
was the fact that many
species of sharks off course
are powerful predators.
Big apex predators.
And there's an
attraction to that.
I wanted to experience
that for myself up close.
For those of you who
have dived with sharks,
I think you can attest
to the fact that,
there is this seductive
blend of grace and power
that sort of exudes
from these animals.
It's palpable when
you're in their presence.
But as a photographer, I
also became somewhat obsessed
with sharks from a
visual perspective.
Throughout millions of
years, nature has sculpted
these animals to be perfect,
for life in the sea.
These very hydrodynamic bodies.
For me they became a subject
that I just wanted to
constantly photograph and always
wanted to try to showcase.
I wanted to get that
ultimate shark photo.
To really show their
beautiful shape and form.
And there's many
different types of sharks
so it was a lofty goal.
About a decade after I made
that very first
blue shark picture,
I had that very first encounter
in 1982 in the mid nineties,
I made this photo of another
blue shark near my home
in New England and I
went into the water
that particular day
wanting to make a picture
that really showed
and accentuated their
exquisite contours.
This was an animal that
truly has been sculpted
and has that beautiful
long slender body
and those beautiful
big pectoral fins
that help it glide
through the ocean.
It was a bright sunny
day but in order to make
that photograph I selected
a very high aperture
to turn the background
sort of black
and just lit the dorsal
side of the animal
as it passed below me.
That little red thing
streaming off the dorsal fin
is actually a parasitic copepod
a little pelagic hitchhiker
that was adding a dash
of red color to the
otherwise blue background.
So as my work evolved
and continued with sharks
I continued to focus on
these forms and shapes,
looking at individual
body parts.
The dorsal fin of a lemon shark.
In this case adorned
with a trio of remoras,
these parasite fish.
Or the giant unusual head of
a great hammer head shark.
Very bizarre looking animal
that almost looks prehistoric
but scientists actually tell
us that these are animals
that are more evolved than
other species of sharks
because their nostrils
have separated out
to either side of
that giant hammer head
and they sort of have
stereoscopic smell.
They're a little bit of a
one upmanship in the game
of evolution in the ocean.
And I also sort of
developed this fascination
with shark tails.
Most photographers off course
wanna photograph the mouth
or the front end
of the shark but,
I became really attracted,
sort of hypnotized
by the tails.
Many species like
this tiger shark
or Makos and Great
Whites which we'll see
shortly have these
exquisite tails
and a really powerful tail
and you know now with
digital photography
I had the luxury of being
able to shoot more frames,
not relegated to 36
on a roll of film
so I could experiment more and
take these kinds of pictures
and sort of satisfy this
weird obsession I have
with shark tails.
But one of the other things
that was important to me,
one of the things that I
tried to do with photography
was to make pictures
that allowed us
or allowed animals like
sharks to sort of display
their exceptional biology.
Sharks have evolved over
hundreds of millions of years,
they haven't really changed in
hundreds of millions of years
because they're perfect for
their life in the ocean.
But I wanted to make
images that would allow
lets say the text in a story
to talk about some
of these features,
like their eyes.
Most sharks have eyes that
are exceptionally good
in dark water.
We know that a cat can see
really good in dark light
but sharks can see twice
as good as the cat can.
And these animals have
skin that is made up of
millions of tiny little teeth,
they're called dermal
denticles but they're very
hydrodynamic and help the
animal efficiently swim
through the ocean
and I don't know
if you can see in the photo
but they've also evolved
these little dots on their
nose, on their snout there.
These are called ampullae of
Lorenzini and they're a nerve
ending that allows the shark
to detect electrical impulses
in the water like the
beating heart of a fish.
So if they're hunting
in very murky water
where eye sight doesn't work,
they can use those
ampullae of Lorenzini
to hone in on their prey
so just amazing predators
and being able to make pictures
that allowed the text to talk
about that was important.
And in terms of evolution
I also wanted to show
that you know, a shark is
not as a shark as a shark,
that they've all developed
and evolved morphologically
for the environment that
they happen to inhabit.
And even with things
like their teeth,
they're not all the same at all.
This is a sand tiger shark
that I photographed in Japan
and you can so those sort
of long slender teeth
that the sand tiger has
which are very different
than a regular tiger shark.
This is a tiger shark
and you can see those
sort of triangular
serrated teeth here
that the tiger shark has
which are used for
chumping into their prey
which is often things
like sea turtles,
sorry for the sea turtle
fans in the audience.
But they're very different.
So making these kinds of
pictures helped, I think readers
and helped give some
dimension to these animals.
And I also wanted to photograph
species like the whale shark
which doesn't have teeth at all
or the teeth that it
has are very very small.
This is a plankton feeder.
Not a predatory shark but the
biggest fish in the ocean.
This is one that I
photographed in Mexico
and was sort of entranced
by this living
wreath of bait fish
that was encircling its head
as I was free diving
alongside of it there
that day in these coastal
waters that were very green.
I actually saw my very fist
whale shark in western Australia
back in 1995.
Giant animal and I can remember
we were using spotter planes
to go out and sort of find them
and then when they found one
they would radio to the boat
and tell us where it was
and we'd position ourselves
way in front of it
and I would slip into the water
and just sort of wait there
snorkeling for this
animal that materialized
out of the blue and it was like
swimming next to a dinosaur.
That's the closest
thing I could imagine.
Just silently emerges and
then sort of fades off
into the gloom.
But despite my own personal
fascination and love
of sharks I realized
that these are animals
that for many people
are something to fear,
something that they don't like.
There's still the old adage
that the only good shark
is a dead shark and sharks
have been portrayed as demons
something that must be killed.
This has certainly been true
in modern times off course
with films like Jaws.
Even though Jaws sort
of demonized sharks,
I have to say I do love that
film, but for other reasons.
But we were sort of demonizing
and villainizing these
animals long before Jaws,
the book or the movie came out.
This is a painting that was
done by John Singleton Copley
in 1778 that's called
Watson and the Shark
and it shows this monster like
shark about to eat this woman
that's fallen in the
ocean and all these people
are being terrorized and I
think for a very long time
sharks have been
portrayed as these
sort of shadowy one
dimensional monsters
that don't have
any depth to them.
They're just out there
waiting to eat us
the second we put
our toe in the ocean
and the reality
off course is that
although they are predators
and have the potential
to do harm to humans,
we're definitely
not on the menu.
These are actually
rather complex animals,
science is only beginning
to fully understand them,
but they're very very
complex creatures
and they play a vital role
in the health of the ocean.
So as I worked on new
stories for the magazine,
I wanted to produce images
that would allow people
to see sharks in new
ways, in new light,
and help change some of these
misconceptions that exist.
Whenever possible I
wanted to make images
that showed sharks
within their environment
because what we've
learned over time
is that healthy ecosystems
in the ocean depend
on healthy populations
of predators,
particularly
animals like sharks.
This is an image that I made
of a Black Tip Reef Shark
in a place called Millennium
Atoll out in the middle
of the central South Pacific.
One of these places that
because of its remoteness
has remained largely unspoiled
and it's a very sharky place.
The biomass of predators like
sharks is very high there
and there's a direct correlation
between the number of sharks
and the health of
the coral reefs.
This is science that Enric
Sala and his Pristine Seas team
who I think might
be here tonight,
have sort of proven.
And I saw it not only in these
places but in other places.
I was on an assignment
for the magazine
a number of years
ago in New Zealand
doing a story on marine reserves
and I was in Fiordland,
this very shadowy,
sort of Lord of the Rings place.
And diving in the
temperate water there.
And I was photographing
macro life on the wall,
these colorful
little tiny animals.
And I looked up and in
the distance saw this
Sevengill Shark a very
prehistoric looking animal
sort of coming at me
so I swapped my macro
rig for a wide angle
that my assistant was holding
and was able to
make a single frame.
But again the correlation
is between healthy
shark populations
and healthy oceans, it's
a direct correlation
and that's what I've learned.
So whenever possible,
I wanna make images
that sort of speak
to that relationship.
It was the same
everywhere I went.
You'd go to places that
saw dead coral reefs
in parts of the Caribbean lets
say and you just didn't see
many sharks.
Or I went to the Bahamas,
places in the Bahamas
where the reefs
were pretty healthy
and there were lots
of sharks around
so you could see it,
it was quite evident.
And in my work as it evolved,
I also wanted,
particularly in the stories
for National Geographic, I
wanted to try to show readers
a little bit more of
the lives of sharks,
a little bit more
of the life cycle.
Particularly focusing for a
period of time on baby sharks,
on shark pups.
Because at the time I made
this photo of a lemon shark pup
in Bimini in the Bahamas,
I hadn't really seen
a lot of images of
this kind of thing
but it's a very important
part of the equation.
Most folks just wanna look
at the big scary sharks
with the jaws and the
teeth and the blood
and that kind of thing but,
this is an important part
of the equation.
Lemon shark pups have their
babies in mangrove nurseries
in these very shallow
places where trees grow
out of the water.
And it's a place where big
predators can't get in.
And the lemon sharks live
for the first two to three
years of their lives
in these nurseries
where they feed and
eventually get big enough
to go out and
compete on the reef.
But this was a fairly
new born lemon shark pup
that was maybe only
12 inches in length
swimming in about a
foot deep of water.
I spent days laying
in that mangrove
trying to get the sharks
to build up their courage
and come close and
after I left this place,
I'd learned that some
of these mangroves
had been bulldozed
so that a golf course
could be made for a resort.
This is the only shark
nursery for a 150 miles around
and it's critical habitat
so these are vital.
So having images like this
within the context of a story
I think helps people to
understand the importance
of protecting places like this.
And whenever possible I
also wanted to show behavior
with sharks, it's a little
hard to do sometimes
but we're working on a story
about the Mesoamerican Reef,
it's the second largest
barrier reef in the world.
I was able to photograph
Caribbean reef sharks
predating on lion fish.
Now as you may know lion
fish are invasive species
in the Atlantic ocean.
They've sort of just exploded
and there haven't really
been any great solutions
to eradicating them.
There's some places
where divers will go down
and try to spear them and
it's had some low level impact
but in Roatan in Honduras
there was a shark biologist
that over a couple of years
had been trying to train
the local Caribbean reef
sharks to acquire a taste
for these, he'd initially
spear them and feed em to them
and over time they began to
naturally predate on them
and it was controlling
the population,
they were beginning to go down
and naturally predate on that.
So that was important too.
But at the end of the day,
I mostly really hope that
by showing sharks as
something beautiful,
as just beautiful
animals, making pictures
that would intrigue the reader
and making them wanna know more
might dispel some of that fear.
Again that shadowy, looking
at pictures like Copley,
Copley that just make
them look like monsters
isn't gonna help anything.
But if we can show these
animals as more beautiful,
maybe not quite dolphins,
but certainly
something to marvel at.
And while working on a story
about sharks of the Bahamas
a few years for the Magazine.
I spent 18 days in winter
time in the Bahamas
trying to get a photo of the
elusive great hammer head
that we see here but,
because of the rough weather
that we had at
that time of year,
I only had two days where
I could actually work
and I made this frame on the
very last night at sunset
when this big fourteen foot
male sort of just swirled in
just below the surface.
But the idea was that my hope
is that a photo like this
might engage people or
readers in the magazine,
they wanna read the caption
and hopefully the story
and learn that hammer head
populations in the last 20 years
or so in the Atlantic ocean
have declined about 89%.
These are animals that we
don't know very much about,
we don't know where they
travel to or from necessarily,
we don't know where they mate,
we don't know where
they have their pups.
And we're loosing them faster
than we can learn about them
so, to be able to make
beautiful pictures
or engaging images of sharks
I think is a big part of it.
The fact is almost
every species of shark
out there in the world
is in real trouble,
certainly all the
predatory species
and they really
do need our help.
So as my career evolved,
I wanted to turn my camera
toward some of the darker side
of what was happening
to sharks as well
because I felt it was
necessary to show people
what was happening
to these animals
and the global slaughter
that was occurring
around the world.
A lot of sharks
are killed for food
but the truth is
this is wildlife
and every single year
right now on planet earth,
more than a 100 million
sharks are being killed.
I mean think about that number.
A 100 million sharks.
We can't kill a 100
million apex predators
and expect any
ecosystem to be healthy
and that's certainly
the case here so,
as I worked on these
kinds of stories,
I sort of got away from trying
to make beautiful pictures
and approached it more
like war photography.
I wanted to make images that
would grab people's attention
so it was dead sharks
being cut up on a beach
or a dead Mako
shark in a gill net.
And showing another Mako here
on the beach being finned.
You know most of those
sharks, the 100 million
or whatever the actual number is
maybe more than a 100 million.
Most of those are
killed for their fins
for the soup fin business,
in the shark fin soup
that's very popular in Asia.
And that's what's
happening here,
they fetch a very high price,
so that's the first thing
that the fisherman goes for.
And as I was working on
this story, I wanted,
it was a story about
the global fish crisis,
the problems of overfishing
and shark fishing
was a big component of that.
I really wanted an image that
would create some empathy
for these animals.
I think this picture
might have done it,
but it was actually one morning
when I jumped in the water
in the sea of Cortez
came along a gill net,
where this Thresher shark
had just recently died
and its eye was still open
and because it's a pelagic
animal, it had these
great big pectoral
fins like we saw
on the blue shark earlier
and as I framed it up
in my camera's view finder
it sort of struck me
as a crucifixion and
I thought that maybe
that would give some
empathy to these animals
that really are in
trouble and need our help.
It became the lead picture
in that cover story in 2007
but it's gone on to
have a life beyond that.
Being used by a
number of conservation
organizations as well
to sort of beat that drum
and help people understand
the plight of sharks.
So all of this sort of
prelude brings me to
the work that I recently
did for National Geographic,
these series of four stories
about some of the top
predatory species of sharks.
As Greg mentioned, we ran
three of them this summer
in June, July and August
and we have one story
yet to be published,
a story on Mako sharks
that will be upcoming.
And you know I think my
hope was that by doing that
as I mentioned
earlier consecutively,
readers would come to see
these animals as different,
as to some degree
having personality
and as being something that
we can, not only respect
but really marvel at.
I don't have any illusions
that sharks or fish
which is what they
are off course
will ever be held
in the same regard
that a fury mammal, I think
we have a national affinity
to terrestrial animals,
particularly cute animals
that live in the forest but,
I do think that if we
can show these animals
as miracles of evolution
then maybe we can
get some respect
and if we get the
respect then appreciation
and move that dial a little
bit in terms of conservation,